Why not?
Now?
This is a good time.
As the 20th century starts to wind down
a few more years as we get ready for
century 21,
what a good time to set your goals,
work on yourself,
work on your skills.
What a good time to get it together?
What a good time to start this process,
personal development,
growing,
changing,
developing,
having a good plan for your money and
for your life and for your future.
Why not was
no opportunity is wasted.
Listen to me carefully.
God,
let's do me very carefully.
You got to hear what I'm saying.
This is important.
They're 86,000,
400 seconds in a day and if you maximize
each and every one of them,
you will live like you want to live.
You will have what you want to have and
you will be what you want to be.
You can have more than you've got
because you can become more than you
are.
If you just remain how you are,
you'll always have what you've got,
but if you're willing to make changes,
the next five years of your life can be
totally different than the last one.
If you don't change,
chances are excellent.
The next five will be like the last
fall.
For things to change,
you've got to change for things to get
better.
It's not what happens that determines
your future.
It's what you do about what happens.
Direction determines destination.
All you got to do is make a little
change in direction to arrive at a brand
new destination in two years,
three years,
five years,
user have to change your life.
That is.
She kind of said,
you know what?
My body is on there.
I'm going to go work out.
My relationship isn't there.
I'm going to change it.
I'm not making what are going to make.
I'm going to retool.
I'm going to get a new skill.
I'm going to go back to school.
I'm going to start a business.
I'm going to do something.
You have to do something to change your
life or in order for you to be happy.
You can't change your life.
You're going to have to change your
blueprint.
Usually in life.
It requires a little bit of beach.
Does that make sense?
And if you've changed your take,
change your life and change your
blueprint.
You can have an extraordinary life
because all of us are going to have
times in our life when we want or think
life should be like,
isn't gonna match how life really is?
Those moments?
If we blame our life goes into pain.
If we change,
we can change our life and match our
blueprint.
The fact that you're not happy has
nothing to do with what you have or
don't have.
The fact that you're an unhappy is that
your life doesn't match the way you
think it should be.
You have some idea of how you think it
should be.
Listen to me.
There are.
Those of you are.
What you're doing is that they're are 10
opportunities in a day and you're taking
advantage of it.
If you think you're doing something
right.
Yeah,
you gotta hear me,
you gotta hear me.
You only have 24 hours in a day,
and you've heard me say this time and
time again,
the way you spend your 24 hours,
it determines how you live.
If you want the future to change for
you,
you've got to change.
If you don't change,
the next six years of your life is going
to be just like the last six.
You'll still be behind on your bills.
You'll still be behind on your promises.
No opportunity wasted.
Again,
no opportunity wasted.
If one of us can do it,
hey,
we all can do it.
Now,
here's my last question.
Why not?
Now
we all have this negative self talk that
goes in our head.
Guess what?
There's enough people that are telling
us we can't do it,
that we're not good enough.
Why do we want to tell ourselves that we
know for fact that thoughts influence
actions.
We sat there with the,
um,
with the video sheldon,
Dr Levy,
so right.
We know that our thoughts influence
actions.
Why do we want to see that negative self
talk to ourselves?
We need to get our own self-affirmation.
Muhammad Ali,
what was his self affirmation?
I am the greatest.
Who else is going to tell you you need
to be quiet moments in your bedroom,
quiet moments when you're brushing your
teeth that we need to reaffirm,
I am the captain of my ship and the
master of my fate.
That is my affirmation and looking
forward to a time that I would feel good
again,
helped me to keep moving forward and
sometimes I had to be brave and it
wasn't always easy.
Sometimes I faltered,
I had bad days,
but I realized that being brave is
supposed to be easy.
And for me,
I feel it's the key way to keep moving
forward.
So all at all,
I don't waste energy feeling bad for
myself.
Uh,
I surround myself with people that I
want to be with and I keep moving
forward.
So with this philosophy,
I hope that all of you,
regardless of your obstacles,
can have a very happy life as well.
Shit,
if I don't see it,
if I don't believe you that no one else
will
get the people.
There's enough of that Mohammed Ali.
I am the greatest.
There is no one better than me.
It's a difference between Hubris and ego
and false pride.
It's just reminding yourself and quiet
silent moments.
I put it down on the list.
It's right beside my mirror
in Russia
and Japan ever met in,
made in America the whole world,
but better than all of those before.
Thank you.
I'm not gonna argue with you.
You're going to be just like some of
your already there.
Well,
you don't know how you're going to make
this happen,
but you just feel within yourself some
way somehow with the help of God,
I'm going to make it happen.
Repeat after me please.
No matter how bad it is,
oh,
how bad it gets.
I'm going to make it.
I'm going to make it
shake someone's hand on your right and
left and say you got the right stuff.
So yes,
it's possible for you to live your dream
because it's not about where you come
from.
It's about.
That's number one.
Number two.
Number two,
I want to make sure you got it.
Isn't as
though the important thing is this
right?
Mom said,
listen to me.
The most important thing is to be able
to sacrifice what for what
alligator.
Adam handcuff lightening undone jail.
Last week I'm murdering Angelo stone.
Hospitalized the brick eric.
I'm so mean.
I make medicine sick
fast,
fast.
Last night I cut the light off in my
bedroom.
Get switched.
Was in the band for the room.
Was dog better fast?
You George Foreman.
Oh,
you chumps bow.
When I whip him.
Oh,
I know you got him.
I know you got him picked,
but the man's in tomorrow.
I'm going to show you how great I am.
A lot of people tried to talk her side
of it.
A lot of people didn't understand it
by the people weren't ready for it.
Ready for it,
but I want to remind you mind to
continue to dream
and dream big.
Dream big.
They didn't call my name.
Go for you to live life with regrets.
I want you to remember this.
Every time you walk in the room
with anybody,
anybody,
right
know that you're special.
No that you mean something to this
world.
I don't care what you started at.
I don't care who told you what you
couldn't.
I believe
I don't care if nobody liked your
status,
family members turning back on
negative.
People want to keep coming to your life.
There's a bigger dream waiting for you,
waiting
for you to step into it,
a bit to it,
to step into it.
Your life is big.
Your life is huge,
huge,
and we spend so much time wanting to be
in somebody else's life.
When I was young,
I had a lot of people telling me,
you have to adjust to the other ones,
the other ones,
you have to be like the other ones.
I was listening,
but I wasn't always following.
I dragged it in.
How do you say I was listening,
but I did my own thing,
my own thing.
I kept doing my own thing and I believed
in myself.
I kept going and it brought me where I
am today.
Confidence in believing what you do.
I think that is the goal.
Target
have to be relentless.
You have to never let off the gas.
Gas,
never stop,
never quit.
Never allow anyone to talk you out
of the dream division and ideas that God
has sent you.
It doesn't matter how many times you get
knocked down.
It's about getting back up,
so if there's any kid out there that's
told by a parent or a coach or a teacher
or somebody that they look up to,
somebody that's supposed to push them
and believe in them and they're told,
no,
don't listen to them.
Believe in yourself.
Sometimes the outcome isn't always what
you desire it to be,
but the true failure in life is not
trying at all
and the master
no
get in line just because other people
are.
I'm only talking to the people that are
ready to get to the next level of a life
in their career and they're going to
boldly walk into the next season of
their life.
Unapologetically getting rid of all
things people in situations that no
longer belong in their life.
Most of you,
most of you,
you're so consumed
with everything that's going on in the
world.
This is the reason you haven't figured
out your own life yet.
Every blog,
every website,
every tweet,
every instagram post,
you are so consumed with everything
that's going on in the world.
You're ignoring your own world.
You can never shine trying to sit on
someone else's son.
You can never figure out who you are if
you're consumed in everything that
everybody else is and what they're doing
in the moves that they're making because
you're trying to chase someone else's
life trying to chase someone else's
lifestyle and identity all while
ignoring your own life and your own
path.
What is the vision for your life?
What are the ideas and the dreams for
your life?
What are you supposed to be doing?
Who are you?
What are your gifts and talents?
What is your ultimate destiny and your
goals
and you should understand this,
that it was always going to be your
family and your friends.
That would be the first ones to try and
talk you out of your vision and your big
idea.
That's why you supposed to live your
life,
focused on your intentions and do your
thing.
Did you allow yourself
to be based on what other people think
of you?
Is the beginning of the end,
I believe in me.
If you stopped believing in me,
I'm not going to believe in myself any
less.
If you believe that I'm irrelevant,
that no one is checking for me and that
I don't mean anything to the world
because you think or believe that about
me,
it doesn't mean that I'm going to
believe it about myself.
See,
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the hand.
Most of you guys don't actually know
your self worth.
You don't know yourself.
Value,
believe in yourself.
Believe in yourself,
independent of the validation of the
world.
I have opinions and feelings about
yourself,
independent of the feedback.
I really think,
and if you get rid of the trash in your
life,
that can be people,
business and situations.
Youtube couldn't really like.
I really believe that you can reach your
full potential.
I want you
to fly.
I want you in your career and your
financial blessings to bypass me.
When I was a kid,
I can go through,
um,
a math book in a week.
So I'm going to have chocolate Ganache,
stockbroker,
stop focusing,
not an astronaut,
but I listened to what Jim Bob on will
say at 21 years,
the most poignant seven words ever
uttered in any speech anywhere.
Don't give up.
Don't ever give up.
Those great people didn't.
So I now have a responsibility to also
not ever give up.
I'm not special.
I just listened to what the man said,
but I'd say there is some times in life
where you fall down,
feel like,
like you don't have the strength to get
back on.
I will try 100 times to get up and if I
fail 100 times,
if I fail and I give up,
do you think that I'm ever going to get
up
and fail and try again and again and
again.
For as long as I'm trying to getting up,
don't quit.
The secret is not keeping up.
Everybody who's done something great,
they weren't that deep resiliency.
They have the ability to bounce back all
the way.
Just
stay on course.
I guarantee you cannot pass it.
If you quit.
I guarantee you,
you don't know what's going to happen.
If you keep going,
I'm prejudiced,
I feel pain.
I heard I opened my eyes.
A great victory.
Do not give up.
I feel no fear.
I fear no man.
I create.
Conquer that.
Hold the power.
Make a choice.
Just decide what is going to be,
who you're going to be,
how you're going to do it.
Just decide and then from that point the
universe is going to get out your way.
We can have another bad year.
You got to get to the point where enough
is enough.
It's much easier to come up with excuses
why you can't do it.
If you do what is easy,
your life will be hard.
If you do want to say is complain about
your situation and circumstances,
surrender and give up on your dreams.
Become depressed and bitter and angry.
Anybody can do that.
If you do what is easy,
your life will be hard,
would have you do what is Paul?
Keep coming back again and again and
again.
Get up dressed every day.
Take life,
taking life by the column.
You say,
yes,
I can do this,
and you've said to yourself,
I'm willing to face the nose.
I'm willing,
I'm willing to.
I'm willing to make this happen.
It's,
it's possible.
It's necessary.
It's hard.
It's worth it to do whatever it takes.
I can do it.
If anybody has ever done at any point in
time in history than what's possible for
one,
it's possible for me and I'm going to
deal with,
and if you do that and over
and over again,
your life will be easy.
I want you to stop gathering information
from outside yourself.
Start gathering the inside.
He made a mistake
and he paid for his mistake with a lot
of pain,
a lot of tears,
and there came to a point where he knew
he should've gotten a divorce,
but he was stuck.
He was stuck in something called
revenge.
He said,
she's made me so miserable.
I'm gonna.
Pay Her back.
He was stuck and he stayed in there
longer than he should have because it
began to us.
Attack him.
It began to affect them psychologically.
Mm.
He took that same attitude to other
relationships.
Looking for something to go wrong,
he was burned so badly,
he did not want to risk pain again.
He was going in relationships,
trying to avoid pain when it became too,
cause he will do something to make sure
the relationship did not work.
He would always try and find something
wrong with it.
The person,
because they're not perfect people,
so if you look forward,
you can find it.
He was stuck in revenge.
Is it difficult?
Sure isn't anything that's worthy of
character building.
Sometimes I have to forgive the same
people over and over and over again.
However,
forgiveness is a practice worth
cultivating,
worth experiencing.
When you forgive somebody for something
that you perceived that they've done
wrong to you,
you are releasing that animosity,
that energy,
that ill will,
that you're harboring inside,
and it's a lot more difficult than just
merely saying,
I'm sorry,
how did I get depressed to who I am
today?
Because I tell you I was depressed when
I was age eight.
I used to concentrate on the things I
didn't have.
I wish I had arms,
legs and I wish I could do this,
but what can I do?
You see?
I have a choice and that's what I want
to talk about today.
Choices,
I can either be angry for not having
arms and legs will be thankful for my
chicken.
Drumstick,
you see,
I can still do a lot of things at home.
I can brush my teeth,
comb my hair,
get myself ready in the morning.
I'm traveling around the world.
It's amazing.
It's a choice.
That is what I want to live.
My life can't always be happy.
Listen,
I know I'm not crazy.
I realized the realism in always been
happy.
Sometimes you have to put up with crap
in your life,
but if we're always striving to choose
happiness everyday you wake up and you
say to yourself,
I'm going to choose to not let the
outside influences in the world affect
my mood.
I'm going to be in charge of how I feel
because I am a choose happiness.
I promise you,
you will leave a lot happier life.
At least.
At least you can try to write.
You just have to set the necessary
conditions for health necessity,
incentives for health,
both for yourself and your children.
If you have that set incentives for
sickness,
I felt depressed,
I felt miserable.
I felt at times where it may be better
to take my life,
but with the wisdom that I gathered in
my 33 short years of life,
I've come to realize that it's just
feeling and in the same way that
chameleon cold is diminished.
The misery of feeling cold is diminished
by the insight that spring will come is
the same feeling that you should
acknowledge the same law,
that you should have knowledge that no
matter how miserable things are right
now,
it is just a season.
It's going to pass the thing that keeps
one living,
his sense of future,
that there will be a tomorrow,
tomorrow to do this,
and then the day after I got to do that.
Not that any of these things tick
and convincing reason to exist,
they somehow keep one going in.
In the words of Dorothy Parker,
great job,
which
you might as well live.